notre deuxième sujet ce soir c'est celui
de 1000 à millas et 7
cette lycéenne elle est en seconde elle
aime bien chanté elle aime le montrer
sur son compte instagram et puis au
cours d'une discussion se fait
lourdement draguer sur internet elle est
conduit la porte 1 et finalement tout
cela donne lieu à des échanges
finalement qui se transforme en menace
menaces à caractère religieux et puis le
ton monte et mila qu'à un vocabulaire
assez vigoureux dit tout de go ce
qu'elle pense de la situation
on écoute la séquence qui a fait
polémique ensuite le sujet a commencé à
déraper sur la religion
donc moi j'ai clairement dit ce que j'en
pensais parce que j'ai la liberté
d'expression tu connais me suis pas gêné
pour dire ce que j'en pensais je déteste
la religion le coran est une religion de
n ya que de la haine là dedans
l'islam c'est de la merde c'est ce que
j'en pense moi je dis ce que je pense
[ __ ] alors la vidéo un peu haché parce
que c'est une vidéo instagram et on
comprend bien le sens de ces propos
aujourd'hui elle est déscolarisé elle ne
peut plus se rendre au lycée elle est
harcelée d'insultés de menaces endroit
emmanuelle barbara ce qu'elle est allée
trop loin
enfin je me suis fait plusieurs
réflexions en écoutant voir une écoute
en lisant plutôt la totalité dans le
fond de des éléments de fait si je puis
dire en valais départ à des passages de
2,2 divers de divers réseaux sociaux
autour de ceux de ce sujet là et j'ai
été frappé d'abord par une extrême
virulence enfin il ya le pardon mais
quelle que soit avant deux pas de la
religion mais ne serait-ce que parler de
soi ou de l'autre d'autrui c'est
littéralement épouvantable enfin on ne
s'exprime pas on ne se connaît pas que
je sache est un sujet réseaux sociaux ça
oui
enfin vous voyez ça faisait pas d'accord
je suis très 20e siècle
aurillac mais justement de jeu me dit tu
entends la parole un peu comment
dirais-je apprise maîtrisé dans ce que
l'on la différence que l'on fait entre
je parle à quelqu'un que je connais et
même le quelqu'un que je connais je dois
reconnaître que c'est quand même
enfin c'est déjà 13 outrancier vous
voyez donc a fortiori j'envoie sur les
ondes avec ce même vocabulaire dont on
peut vraiment dire qu'il dépasse
absolument toutes les bornes raisonnable
et c'est hélas et d'autre mais de part
et d'autre parce que ça commence cette
espèce de deux montées réciproque monte
très vite en réalité ça c'est là que mes
enfin la vidéo manquait plus que la
vidéo mais si on se contentait juste des
échanges écrits entre tous et c'est ces
gens qui ne se connaissent pas on est
déjà saisi bon alors déjà je me suis dit
en un instant je suis au delà de sutton
et c'est acquis mais qui m'a heurté en
tant que maire en tant que citoyen en
tant que tout ce qu'on veut je suis
portée par la manière je me suis dit
avant de poser des questions j'ai l'air
s'agissant de l'entrain parle de jeunes
gens
mais si ceux ci ou le quart de la moitié
de ceux-ci et est arrivé dans un univers
que je connais mieux à mon métier
l'entreprise
voyez imaginer des collègues qui eux
naissance quand je parle de retour dans
l'entreprise et pas très bien venir
non mais par exemple une voyez ce qu'il
en est une insulte du solde du sol au
plafond jir du début à la fin de cet
incident généreux dans les phases c'est
à dire je te drague lourdement je te
réponds créera je mets en cause quelques
stigmates les pièces pour les contextes
que mamilla s'affiche ouvertement
voilà donc qui met également on est dans
l'outrance j'aime pas fabre on va par
exemple les insultes fusent mais voilà
et je me dis dans des relations de cette
nature conduisent immanquablement à a
licencié les belligérants jeudi les
protagonistes cette affaire c'est à dire
qu'en fait qui est le premier du
deuxième il ya un moment donné où
l'histoire de provocation et sur
provocation donc voilà ça c'est le
premier point c'est que du coup on est
tellement dans l'outrance que ça après
chercher qui a raison de qui c'est là où
nous sommes prise à témoin par l'ampleur
des réseaux sociaux qui fait du coup
nous autres enfin laitières et sur le 50
ans avaient le droit de dire moi je
déteste cette religion mais bien sûr que
c'est toujours pareil phrase à phrase on
peut dire que je n'aime pas une religion
on peut dire on a le droit de dire ça
parce que c'est la question entre le
blasphème qui n'est pas poursuivi versus
là en france
en france bien sûr à la différence de 2
des insultes l'insulté est un problème
en droit français
donc je vois là enfin il faut il faut
quand même regarder sous l'angle enfin
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit en l'état
compte tenu de cette cette anecdote
d'aller d'aller donner des
qualifications juridiques voire
judiciaire c'est tard parce que dans le
fond c'est une enfin cessé au delà d'une
cour de récré m'enfin c'est celle à
laquelle je le pub adressé au public une
espèce de deux de vomissements en
réalité de qui est qui et rupture voilà
et il s'agit après d'aller chercher des
responsabilités et puis en plus de
prendre parti je suis désolé moi je n'ai
personnellement je ne crois pas parti
parce que ça dépasse si je puis dire le
caractère ne serait-ce que raisonnable
eco et normal des interactions entre
entre personnes a fortiori lorsqu'on
prend à témoin le public du fait des
réseaux sociaux est donc au total ça
donne
ben voilà ça donne une polémique
supplémentaire et au bout du compte
cette jeune fille elle est en l'état en
l'état actuel n'est pas scolarisé il ya
peu plus à l'est dans son école et à la
police dans son bain voilà un réalisme
en est d'ailleurs à liège on ne peut
plus masquer dans aucun établissement
parce que la france entière
oui voilà la marque tient bon tout ça
est un peu excessif la france entière et
c'est fait c'est déjà incroyable que
c'est que cet incident et puis avoir
lieu je trouve ça déplorable en fait
actuel devait qui ont lancé ces
déclarations parce que moi je touche je
peut déplorer l'horizontale et l'extrême
horizontalité des réseaux sociaux les
propos à l'emporte-pièce etc mais je
trouve c'est un pelage de renvoyer dos à
dos les protagonistes moi ce qui me
choque quand même le plus dans cette
histoire c'est que elle ne peut plus
puissent plus aller à l'école il ya d'un
côté des propos effectivement de cour de
récréation qui autrefois ne se seraient
pas retrouvés sur la place publique
parce que les réseaux sociaux
n'existaient pas et en face des menaces
de mort c'est pas tout à fait je crois
la même chose et là encore ça pose la
question certains quartiers dans notre
république comment se fait-il que lui
doivent mettre la police pour aller à
l'école aujourd'hui donc et là il ya un
problème de société majeur sur sur le
poids de
dindane islamisme conquérant qu'on voit
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on voit dans
les quartiers et qui veut empêcher la
liberté d'expression qui est vraiment le
sujet problématique dans cette histoire
donc dire on les renvoie dos à dos ça
n'aurait pas dû se passer comme ça je
trouve que c'est un peu facile parce que
ce qui est plus grave quand même c'est
effectivement cette pression exercée par
les islamistes aujourd'hui sur la
société moi je trouve ça très bien les
réseaux sociaux ont plein de défauts
mais finalement je trouve ça pas mal ça
a provoqué en réaction beaucoup de gens
qui l'ont défendu qui sans doute partagé
pas ces propos ni son style mais qui ont
voulu faire entendre qu'on était encore
dans un pays libre où on pouvait dire un
certain nombre de choses même des
maladresses même des bêtises sont sans
risquer sa vie
ça c'est un côté positif finalement des
réseaux sociaux parce que je crois qu'on
réglera notamment ce problème de la
pression islamiste par des lois etc par
l'état mais aussi par le retour d'un
certain nombre d' un certain contrôle
social et finalement que les citoyens
s'emparent de sujets et fassent entendre
leur voix c'est pas mal mais est-ce
qu'on peut aller manger par exemple ne
seraient pas allés
jusque jusqu'à ce qu'on veut dans la
liberté d'expression en autriche
notamment par exemple une personnalité
politique avait été sanctionné pour deux
pour avoir qualifié le prophète de
pédophiles oui mais en attendant
toujours blessé pas la magie station
évidemment en autriche les ondes et ce
pour la france ils ont des crucifix dans
les églises et aux états unis il
enseigne le créationnisme se sont
associés communautarisme et
multiculturel l'église la religion peut
avoir une prévenance tels que leur
président sage unis prête serment
maintenant sur la bible pléthore de
films où il prête serment sur les objets
religieux défendre notre liberté et donc
la france est laïque et donc nous bien
évidemment la république souveraine nous
avons défendu cette jeune fille là et
bien évidemment qu'elle allait
surmaquillée que ces propos simplement
tracé puissant houellebecq s'est pas
coordonnées s'attardera pas terrible oui
mais je rappelle que ce n'est pas
évident c'est très important parce que
la question du droit
ouais c'est pas une leaders d'opinion
elle est sur son compte par alec je sais
pas qui est ce sont d'autres qui diffuse
massivement à l'extérieur et ça prend
une ampleur
j'ai eu des débats depuis hier avec des
gens sur depuis qu'on a soutenu me là
avec des gens des jeunes parfaitement
honnête et il faut là aussi on a un
problème d'éducation de droit sur le
droit en objets qu'ils sortent des
exemples de loi où il écrit qu'on ne
peut pas stigmatiser une personne en
fonction de sa religion mais si la
confusion là on ne peut pas stigmatiser
une personne en fonction de sa religion
si elle disait tu es un sale type parce
que tu es juifs catholiques protestants
bouddhistes ou arabe ou musulman et ben
c'est sanctionnables par contre la lie
la laïcité c'est considérer que les
religions sont des opinions comme les
autres et qu'elles peuvent être
critiqués et si on n'aime pas le
souverainisme parce que nous défendons
souverainisme on peut dire le
souverainisme c'est de la merde
et tout ça c'est débile mais si vous
sera sereine outrancier mais c'est pas
grave alors j'essaie la liberté
d'expression et la france doit
impérativement conserver ça plutôt que
de sombrer dans dans le communautarisme
parce que c'est la porte ouverte après
chacun serait 7 et r
alors oui c'est exact mais de faire sa
direction il a dit être islamophobe
il y en a 10 dans des termes beaucoup
plus châtié puisque saint henri
pena-ruiz ex un grand professeur de
gestion vraiment au delà de la forme
outre haussière au delà des réseaux
sociaux moi je suis un spécialiste des
logiques d'opinion les réseaux sociaux
comme le disait elle opte pour la langue
c'est la meilleure et la pire des choses
il ya des aspects extrêmement positif
mais ça nourrit ça obéit à des logiques
de mobilisation est souvent de n ya eu
cent mille tweets liés à cette personne
me là c'est quand même assez
impressionnant c'est pas une logique
d'opinion publique on est sur une
logique de représentativité et une
opinion plutôt raisonnable on est on
vient de commémorer les cinq ans de la
tuerie de charlie hebdo nous voient nous
venons de poser que pendant un public
une enquête que nous posons chaque année
ce diriez vous que vous sentez vous avez
un esprit chardy on a deux tiers des
français qui disent oui un tiers non
mais on a une césure générationnel une
fois de plus extrêmement forte du côté
des jeunes
on ne se sent pas charlie et quand on
demande aux français pourquoi se
sont-ils charlie qu'est ce que c'est
qu'être charlie c'est avoir la
possibilité d'avoir une forte liberté
d'expression et une liberté de glace m
qui prend le pas sur l'événement charlie
le drame
en tant que parent en tant qu'agent de
millas et un dessin oui je pense qu'on
est sur la on est sûr de notre ancien
des dessins de charlie hebdo qui peuvent
bien sûr il est choqué mais l'opinion
est aussi n'ont plus de vie je
rappellerai on sait très bien que reese
patrick peloux zineb el rhazoui may only
absolument d'enfer c'est vrai j'étais
très intéressé par des propos de cauet
morin que vous avez mis en avant cette
victimisation perpétuelle fait le lit
d'un communautarisme d'un repli sur soi
et ça je dirais mines le ciment
républicain et c'est une perception
partagée par beaucoup de français qui
constitue souvent une minorité
silencieuse peu présent sur la bo
sociaux
merci vous n'êtes pas d'accord d'accord
je sais même pas parler du droit tout à
l'heure c'est pas une question de droit
encore une fois il ya derrière des
menaces de mort on voit bien qu'il ya il
y à il ya un problème que c'est le
symptôme d'un problème plus gros
beaucoup plus gros ou parler du du
communautarisme
effectivement il ya les logiques
identitaires sur twitter mais là aussi
mais quiconque on retrouve
malheureusement dans la société encore
une fois dans certains territoires et
c'est ça qu'il faut je crois aujourd'hui
combattre en priorité et ensuite si elle
pouvait être plus instruites et mieux
éduquer ce serait ce serait parfait mais
mais on ne peut pas interdire interdire
aux jo peut un peu vulgaire ou peu
abstrait ou plus éduqués de s'exprimer
non plus donc de re donc je crois qu
encore d'éducation
on oublie ce qui s'est passé dans ce
pays à l'histoire de ce pays il fut un
temps où on brûlait les gens pour
blasphème et on l'est il faisait un
blasphème contre la religion catholique
le jésus dieu ce que vous voulez comme
le fait d'ailleurs charlie hebdo
également et là ça finisse est malin il
n'est pas qu'on finissait sur les
bûchers fou est écartelé tout impossible
tout dire mais sur toute religion juste
vous rappeler quand même ce qui s'est
passé dans ce pays les gens sont
révoltés contre cette domination d'une
église spécifique en l'occurrence le
catholicisme et l'ont fait d'une manière
extrêmement durs ceux qui trouvent que
on est un peu dur avec l'islam quand on
fait des critiques du lit samedi donc se
rendent pas compte que ça veut dire
faire prêter ou prêtera serment sur la
constitution à genoux ont fusillé
quelques-uns il va faire défaire des
guerres fermé des congrégations c'est
pas juste 13-14 mosquées qui sont fermés
c'est des centaines de congrégation des
arrêtés d'interdiction de la port de la
soutane des gens envoyés à l'étranger
mais si vous voulez absolument vivre
dans des conversations et véhicules et
être dans aller en belgique et en
allemagne
on a chassé faut en fait et c'est comme
ça qu'on est devenu en 1905 laïque après
douze ans après près de cent vingt ans
de
d'affrontements si on perd ça on change
de pays ce qui n'a pas empêché la
l'humoriste fois et frédéric fromet de
chanter une chanson humoristes voilà une
chanson société sur la première ouais
c'était sur france inter rappelant que
beaucoup si c'était un leader d'opinion
que c'était sur france inter dans une
radio publique
qui plus est est donc et moi je trouve
son sketch pas drôle mais tant mieux
s'il est là le droit de le faire je
dirais pas le l'intérieur ce qui est
amusant c'est ici qui s'est excusé
auprès de la communauté homosexuelle et
pas auprès de l'église
l'ailier ce catholique il aura pu faire
les deux soirées étaient plus plus
élégant que la ctq suez comment la jeune
miley s'est excusé hier soir ou ce matin
à envoyer là que s'est emporté ce qui
est ce que les menaces de mort pourrait
peut-être tourner la langue sept fois
dans leur bouche et se dire que oui
c'est peut-être une jeune fille qui
confond un peu il s'est un peu emporté
et que ça ne mérite quand même pas des
poursuites
on déconne une femme la menacer de mort
et le pouvoir et le procureur devrait
poursuivre les gens qui menacent de bord
en raison d'une opinion si on ne le fait
pas c'est très dangereux alors sur nos
internautes sont assez stupéfait et 10
pas sûr que la gamine est bien
conscience de ce qu'elles faisaient les
rappeurs qui insulte à la france des
traditions eux sont très bien vu seach
souligne le communautarisme peau du
surpris non lorsqu'on sait surtout les
torrents de haine qui se déverse sur les
réseaux sociaux là je crois que vous
êtes tous rejoint sur ce point là